focusing press conferences a rarely so
subdued but this is no ordinary fight
there are three heavyweight title belts
at stake that's not the reason Anthony
Joshua is receiving 60 million pounds
for his rematch with American Andy Ruiz
this man is Prince Abdul Aziz is charged
with making Saudi Arabia the next great
power in world sport no matter the cost
the aim to repair a global image heavily
tarnished by alleged human rights abuses
it won't surprise you to learn that many
people don't want this fight in Saudi
Arabia Amnesty International have said
that repression is worsening in this
country and it's a barbaric regime and
this is a form of sports washing what
would you say to them we do have
mistakes like any other country but they
are changes social changes that are
happening that that are that are that
were driving towards that and hopefully
things will get better as we as we as we
as we move on and we are learning as
well is there a perception problem
because as a woman here there's only
certain times of the day that I can go
swimming for instance in the hotel pool
I can't go to the hotel gym does that
need to change if you're going to be
taken seriously as a world power within
sport only two years ago they weren't
allowed to do any sports and now there
are dedicated places that and but we
have to also respect what the people
want as well and the culture that we
have so we though we do want to change
towards the you know positive change and
so on but we also have to make sure that
it's done in the right way
that we don't offend anyone this stadium
has taken just 47 days to build on
Saturday it will host the biggest
sporting event in Saudi Arabia's history
and they say despite the controversy
this is just the start next they're
setting their sights on a football World
Cup in an Olympics in some ways Saudi
Arabia is modernizing undergoing a
radical package of social reform but
this is a country which still carries
out the headings and is accused of
launching a crackdown on critics at home
the man who secured Anthony Joshua the
biggest payday in British boxing history
you don't apologetic what do you say to
people who say sport has no place coming
here well I mean I don't want to push it
on to other people and say well the WWE
do it the PGA Tour do it Formula One do
a formulary and the Dow and Federer do
it but they do and a lot of those are
bigger organizations than ourselves
boxing is different boxing's a fight
sport these guys are taking part in the
most brutal the most dangerous sport out
there and ultimately they will fire
where they will be paid as much money as
possible just two years ago it would
have been inconceivable that Saudi
Arabia might host such a sporting
spectacle now they've got their big
fight the next challenge is proving to
the world they deserve it
Martha Kellner Sky News Saudi Arabia